hey did you see the new Ryan Tron video
uh who's that Ryan Tron the crazy penny
guy you love him Ryan Tran oh is that
what they're calling him these days
anyways the Tron man has a funny video
you got to see stop saying that say some
other YouTubers that you like I I want
to see something well I like Britney
brosi Britney Bros she was on H three
podcast a few times obviously Pew dap
there's no way you actually think it's
pronounced like that Junior egg I
actually don't know how you pronounce
that one
penguinzo penguinzo and obviously when
to go on this is stupid you're being
stupid right hey how do you know you're
pronouncing it right when reading text
alone we often mispronounce things this
is the unique charm of YouTubers also
they just like to pick convoluted names
that can be easily
confused anyways have you seen the new
man crying things video